(upbeat music)
- All right everybody,
let's wrap this hour up
with one last feel good story.
I am excited to share with
you, this is "What I'm Liking."
I am always deeply
impressed when young people
see issues in their
community and instead of
just pointing it out, they
actually do something.
That's completely the case
for For 20-year-old Akayla,
after years of leading projects
and activities for kids
in her Philadelphia neighborhood,
she just opened a full on
community resource center.
So cool.
We have her joining us
now from "Dimplez 4 Dayz."
Everybody say, "Hi!" to Akayla.
Hi!
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Hey guys, hey Kelly.
- Oh my gosh, you do
have dimples for days.
They're so cute.
Oh my God, you're so cute.
Okay, so you've been doing
nonprofit work since you were 13?
- Yes. It all started
when I was 13 years old.
It literally was like, I was dancing
on the app called Dub Smash,
and then I started getting
all of these followers
outta nowhere and my mom was like,
"what are you gonna do with
all of these followers?"
And I really didn't know,
I just knew I always
wanted to help people.
And she was like, well, it
sounds like you wanna be
in the nonprofit world.
At 13 I didn't really know
what the nonprofit world was,
but my mom had prior knowledge in it
so she was able to guide me.
We did know that we wanted our mission
to be helping the community,
being able to give back to the community,
provide resources, and
doing things like that.
So we took off.
We were doing book bag
drives, feeding the homeless,
giving breakfast to the kids,
and from right there, that's what it was.
And like you said, I do have my dimples,
so the name was very much natural.
People were calling me Dimples already.
So with Dimplez 4 Dayz,
that's what it was.
And that's where how
we got our mission too,
keeping the smiles and
the hearts and minds
of the community.
Because every time we came around
people were always smiling.
- I love that.
So now you actually have a brick
and mortar resource center.
So what new opportunities
has that opened up?
- You gotta understand,
like coming from Philly,
there's a lot of violence in Philly.
So with the resource center, yeah,
we're not just this resource center
that you could come in
and work on your resume.
No, you could come in and you can
get those resources that you need.
You could come in, you
can get something to eat,
you can sleep.
You know, it's a safe haven for our youth.
We don't even call them
youth, we call them Dreamers,
because it's a place that
you're turning your dreams into reality.
But we have like certain
days for certain things
for our Dreamers to do.
So on Monday, they'll like paint
to work on their mental health.
On Tuesdays and Wednesdays,
we like to call those
workforce development days.
Thursdays, that's Taco Thursdays,
they're making their tacos.
And then on Fridays,
those are our youth panels
or our teen socials.
All of these are our youth-led activities
because we like to show our
youth that they are the leaders.
They're leading the discussion.
Not only is that building
their self-esteem,
but that's keeping them
from out of the street.
You get what I'm saying?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Keeping them somewhere
safe, in that safe haven.
- And empowering them and
giving them confidence
and that they can do this.
(audience applauding)
And when someone believes in
you, that changes everything.
Thank you so much, Akayla.
Love your dimples.
They make me smile.
I'm liking your post right now, alright?
And that's not all, our
season long partner, Pilot,
pin makers of G2, the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, ma'am,
so they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1000.
How's that sound?
(audience applauding and cheering)
- Thank you, thank you.
- Thank you so much.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Emma Roberts, Ramon
Rodriguez, Dr. Buck Drummond,
Reeny, Maggie, and Nickleback.
Y'all, if you're not having a
great day, try and change it.